2 billionaires think the economy will collapse
bydeux-mille-vingt-quatre
and he bets billions of dollars on this
hypothesis. The 1st,
Michael Berry,
the famous investor of the film The Big Short,
who predicted the
real estate crisis of two thousand and eight.
His bet at the time made him extremely rich.
So he recently took 1 open position,
which means that it is betting against the market for 1
total of $1.6,000,000,
or 90% of its portfolio,
according to CNN Business.
The second billionaire is Warren Buffett.
Of document deposited in host by the sec,
the American agency that monitors and
regulates the financial markets,
showed that Warren would have
sold nearly8.000.000.000 dollars worth of shares
last quarter,
thus increasing its money reserve to
one hundred and forty-seven billion.
But that's not all since
over the past 9 months,
he would also have sold titles for
33 billion dollars.
Many media have described these movements
like 1 bird that
runs to the edge with the anticipation of a recession.
In fact,
Warren Buffett's strategy,
before any crisis,
is to keep a maximum of cash on hand
in order to
r buy when prices are at their lowest.
Still according to CNN Business,
4 major concerns disrupt these investments,
the in savings
Chinese and American,
the Ukrainian Russo conflict
and risks in the banking sector,
of which several investment funds have withdrawn
their actions.
And to follow the economic news,
subscribe to omniscience